I'm going to talk about reactant for
those who don't know where Jack is it's
a JavaScript library for building you I
from facebook and it lets you write the
UI in a declarative way and it's really
good at managing complex you hierarchies
complex why so so it kind of bold like
what i'll be going over i'm going to
start and give you kind of overview of
what is react what are the pieces that
make it up i'm going to demo how you
might take an existing application and
add react to it sort of demo how you
would build a react app and round up i'm
going to then dunno how r z is react
real quickly and wrap off with some the
winds that I think react brings so
there's going to be a little bit of
slides in the beginning but a lot of
code in the middle and i encourage you
to stop me at any point i moving too
fast and if you have any questions so
what is reactive reacts is a couple
things for one it lets you write your UI
and declarative way and what does that
mean when I say declarative and react
you describe the state of your UI and
you write your view your HTML and it's
sort of this machine underneath
interprets that and creates the UI for
you first what you might be more
traditionally used to do on the client
side and javascript is more imperative
way using jquery which is like high this
thing add some asian
here you're constantly manipulating
things explicitly we're actually the app
is more better than saying machine runs
it builds the UI for you the other the
key component of react is what's called
the virtual Dom and so the virtual Dom
is a way to performing Lee make updates
so this is a crazy crazy magic that
underlies react and it's basically a
mini if Dom API and pure JavaScript
except it doesn't include all of the
entire code on just includes the party
is rendering and the way it maintains
its performance is by computing the
differences of updates through react and
only making the minimal amount of
manipulations phenomenon eat soon
because Dom is the most expensive thing
in JavaScript programming javascript has
gotten a lot faster every year since
aumsville it's very slow so react does
it's bet it's best not to manipulate the
Dom that goes into and so how did
facebook come up with this well they
actually reference game engines and
graphics engines and here's a piece of
an image I spoke from one of the react
demonstration slides that is making
parallels to do free game engine and to
how we react works so in do the dupree
engine we calculate all of your state
outside of graphics and then you
actually do the rendering as minimal as
possible after you bash up the diff of
the state of the world similarly react
those all of its state calculations
virtual Dom and then it applies the
mental amount of gifts to the actual
gone finally the one of the key
components or the key parts of reacts is
what's called a component and this idea
of building a component hierarchy and
building and encouraging a one-way data
flow so in other JavaScript MVC
frameworks like backbone or ever angular
you might do an event-driven
architecture where you're making updates
to model that's linked to view the view
mates binds to events in the model
update itself and makes Macleish's on
the models update more views read out
twice take a slightly different approach
where it encourages its unidirectional
data flow and trickling down your
view hierarchy or component hierarchy oh
so is the commercials are literally
ruining the whole part of every single
part of them so this is kind of how
reacts virtual dominance works is by
building up this big component hierarchy
react can say there's one piece of state
change down here and reacts will update
the tree and only make the
Dominy to instead up and say maybe a
very complex event system you might have
once thing inches here and start
triggering things inspire you hierarchy
or black depending on I'm going to see
the code bases so what are components
then this is the building block of react
it is essentially a to the the main
piece that makes react it's react kind
of ascribe assault as the V of MVC if
you want it to be then so components are
the one they're the couple your your
HTML is just as some people even in line
or HTML Javascript sorry and some people
inline CSS into their components and so
it's kind of like you ever heard of web
component to start spec for browsers and
future that are trying to encapsulate
you lie and couple together the related
HTML CSS react to sort of pushing in
that direction by coupling things
logically in sort of conceptual ways
instead of writing them apart by type of
file for instance so I tried to sort of
illustrate this idea and react you kind
of have to think of it simply for those
who are familiar with backbone it would
be like having your template embedded
inside of your view but your template
has all the power of JavaScript has
instead of being something
my mustache is more than 4,000 strategy
HTML whereas I'm like a more traditional
NBC you might be pulling pieces from all
over the place to build up piece of you
I that kind of Christ a couple of those
pieces it's one self-contained marshal q
described a mystery to her interview in
your conceptualization or write extra
rent yeah so that's a good question
because often the server review is
referred to simply as the HTML uh-huh
and many times I have dr. frameworks the
template is time to be equivalent of a
server side view it's to describe HTML
that comes out of it and for instance in
background their views actually actually
controllers and they're sort of the
thing I wraps Dom events and does the
rendering or ties together model it's
two templates so on the client side code
sometimes people actually hurts you view
pretty is lots of views when they're
technically more like controllers that
leading the country in react though this
is all couple together so we act will
have your template invented inside of
angel forward it will climb a perception
I getting together yes I usually I
download you sir I'm
I designed for ya so Facebook I
personally a party we happens we don't
actually have designers adding doing a
lot of HTML but facebook I try to solve
this problem by introducing a
preprocessor called jsx which lets you
write HTML inside of your javascript and
i'll show you how that looks very soon
and they claim that designers of this is
comfortable with j sx as they are with
HTML and CSS and finally components have
two key parts to them to sort of types
of data that they manage and this is
called state and props so state is data
that changes over time and react
encourages that you try to keep your
state as minimal as possible inside of
the component it's simply a hash that
describes whatever say your component is
in something that might going to state
could be the main data such as a
collection of favorites or it might be
strictly dear state such as is this
model code winter clothes either way
both of those things might change over
time of props you can kind of think of
it started refreshing no that's so in a
sense it catches every aspect of the DOM
is a hat so a strike we've gone but it
describes in let me jump ahead see if I
can find it yeah so it's just a vanilla
object that tried sooo
simple vanilla object waves try to the
state of your grandma and so the state
the weights in sight but basically you
describe your down in like Ranbir and
the render function and you will assert
that you owe like do lot of space on
your things you might say imploding ull
I else spinner what these things aren't
instead a couple this state is quickly
data describe the current state of your
client whereas design and so props for
this familiar background think that as
the options object passes will you move
the most part its configuration the or
data that doesn't change over time okay
there's any questions before I jump into
the actual trip which will be the need
of this cool
one second
ok so I'm going to show start by showing
well first of all how many of you have
used bathroom before your agent ok how
many of you use amber angular or their
clients I don't trip and easy ok so
there's a maybe two-thirds of you were
familiar with weights familiar with some
shelter clients at NBC I'm going to demo
how we would take an existing back WI
and you choose back to it and then I'm
going to show the reaction ground up so
for those who aren't familiar with back
by our clients I bbc's please stop me at
any point things are getting really
confusing but um hopefully it won't be
too I'm not going to die too much in the
background I'm going to try to show how
the act might be introduced into a
client side in DC so let's start with
showing you this little bathroom app we
have here that this is actually sore wo
I artsy had at one point which is
favored DUI of course there were a
little bit less kittens on site design
so here you have this thing might you I
where you can favorite kittens light and
the potting of a trade your favorites
and they both are in sync rendering so
quickly one over what that looks like
this will probably get familiar sort of
set up for those nine backbone is that
never I'm ready that you know so at the
top we have two collections collections
to quickly give a rundown for those who
aren't familiar with a friend and
background brutes NBC to the client side
essentially at the guts of it it's got a
view air and a model layer and a model
later can have collections or models
questions are just basically a wrapper
around rates for model and use like I
started alluding to earlier are kind of
like controllers what they play a little
bit of a few role as well and it turns
up like rendering HTML so here we have
two top level collections we have a
kitten's collection which represents
this entire list of kittens and we have
a favorite collection which represents
the tray bottom and I'm not going to
dive too far into the code but this is
more of a typical backward set up where
you have an event-driven system so here
we have a list view this represents
this is why the list of kittens and a
tray view which represents the tray at
the bottom and an initialize function
here which is basically sets up the app
passes in these popover questions why I
was everything together the views
subscribe to events as we can see here
if you are adding and removing to your
favorites it will rear ender and
likewise and list if you're adding a
removable rear ender or house and call
that ok so again don't get too caught up
on the roads not going to back down or
get too caught up on basically
essentially there's these two top level
collection piece of data one that
represents your favorites one that
represents was kittens and two views one
that represents the list one that
represents the tray the bottom so how
would we prove this is like great but we
are really interested in reaction when
introduced react to the staff or not how
would we start being it
well before I dive into this is anyone
views at this point there's any
questions the kid people really confused
strongly this critters budget he'll
catch on so yeah let's go ahead and jump
into it then so the cool thing about
react is you can build your entire
application through a huge component
hierarchy and react and scale that level
but you can also introduce it in the
tiniest piece of the piece of you I
including this now existing application
which is what we're going to do now and
in this case let's try to replace this
tray you I wave react so in space looks
docks to show you how to start building
simplest and mine you could react and
not just basically starts with
describing your HTML comment so here
they show you a hello message that just
has a render function that returns did
with the name that has passed into that
react and so too
for circle back to the j sx point here
that's earlier about how does Facebook
deal with designers we need to adjust
component in cynacia now this is j sx
which lets you in line HTML into your
javascript install a mustache for
handlebars or some kind of template
language embedded writings i can
javascript and it's a preprocessor and
there's a couple ways to enable it in
your app personally i'm going to be
using what's called browserify which is
a node module node is joseline server
site that will read my jsx and outplayed
its grand my jewelry my dress exhale put
some pure duster and if you're
interested in that i talked me
afterwards I can play details that's a
little so going off this the first step
to introducing in react components into
existing app or in general and building
a any reaction point whatsoever is to
start with this render so we're going to
start by just trying to render out the
UI the other factors do good so to
reference the old back when app you can
see here here's our tray view background
view it's got intently underscore
templates which are like pjs or ER de
and it's just a ul and li that iterates
through our kittens and outputs some
ages
so likewise in our jsx we're going to do
something similar where we have a UL
that goes through our favorites maps
them into the lives and spits out images
so this is like the most basic beginning
of a d react we replaced our backbone
view here with a static component that
just renders out some HTML and so what
does that look like when we replace that
so here I'm just running the j sx pool
create some proper JavaScript and I'll
puts the reaction poignant replacing our
back Winfield so you can see here I have
I actually add a little kitten to my
question for start with just using good
old background conventions but nothing
works in this component none of it gets
updated lon favoriting I can't remove
kittens the next step is actually adding
functionality to this many questions
before I don't know that this is
currently is coming from CSS file as you
wouldn't need oh here's my vision so
notice this is like this old-school
bunnell way to SF same reference in a
linked file but some as i'm saying
earlier some people like to even do like
this kind of thing because you can
actually use javascript dynamically
create adjust styling which should be
actually doing useful if you're trying
to do some fancy animate things or not
there's some powerful things you can be
able to meet Ashley properties
for things like this so great pulse is
currently the right career closet
introduction leader yeah so this
reaction create class is basically the
same as essentially equivalent same in
fact when you extend its the plenary
funny when you're doing a good point i
didn't mention how this component gets
added and that is why using react render
so in their their example doc you can
see they create the blast and then they
use react render the particle and then
stops fighting the HTML element exactly
so here you can see this is going to
look pretty similar to what I'm
instantiating a background view this is
the react form of it and that's the
whatsit great books this is this
interesting like mix of functional and
our paradise I think they want to make
it more appealing so I think at the
heart react is like drawing water
functional ideas in the snippet of code
that's in the react documentation in the
browser there yeah the day will be
highlighted mountain what is that that
is the McDonald so we see you can see
Gareth jquery i'm specifying i see so
you're just picking up his own element
out of the jquery exactly so when you
use react render but you have a really
fully react trap
or app this might be like body and then
from there we access it okay so let's
reference to domin yeah exactly all
right question so this is just the
javascript file from it or the Jay
expects file that require so I I'm just
I'm just using browser parents pressured
by there's never prior to going on here
but i'll show you that i'm gonna test
Oriakhi you know that's my co cool so
the next step is to add some
functionality your wrist so in this case
we're introducing reacts to a pretty
typical background app and we're not
going to try to get too deep into react
fiat philosophy yet we just want to
replace a chunk of you I to get our
people out of your life so how do we get
it so that this renders when you
favorite kittens it's not doing anything
right now
you can use reacts very simply like you
would a back from you as you your as you
create Morgan a component becomes less
encouraged to do this because again the
whole view hierarchy in one way data
flow but if you're just introducing a
small trunk it's okay do use force
update and so forth update is
essentially like calling render on a
background of you and so this is going
to look familiar again to those who are
familiar with backbone or a similar
event at NBC points of NBC this is
essentially going to be the equivalent
of doing this kind of thing where
binding to add a move we're calling an
entry point render on how to remove to
the selection likewise in our react app
sorry we're jumping around so much we're
finding to either move and we're calling
the equivalent of render on weak economy
so again this can get messy the more you
try to use force renders I'm an
anti-pattern but for something so really
simple it's totally fine so this breaks
the reactive
so it doesn't necessarily break anything
but as you create larger view
hierarchies it can start to get trickier
to track down where updates I'm acne so
it's like will you say concealer or like
any other right good question sorry I
program so like I was saying earlier
there's two parts to find state and
props props media configuration you
passed in a component so the when you
declare it's sort of like recommends are
sort of right in my HTML element and so
when you declare attributes on it those
are counted cross so in our case here
the only property have his favorites
which is the background reflection we're
passing on it so we recommend supply of
this cross when you go the phone for
sell people so this there yep I don't
see shelf referenced so this is just in
JavaScript scope is a pain yes as you
manage so when you have a call back like
this you will often lose your scope this
is so you have videos i miss the down
below under but yep oh I mean that's
just cuz I didn't she is the preference
I think that's just crossed from before
oh I catch hi we're doing coder be over
okay so worrisome the reserves key
states across state changes drops down
but right the fields attached a problem
change but the values of those fields
Kenji yeah so yeah this is this is an
even facebook like such a small hardest
parts about getting started redact it's
kind of wrapping your head around the
difference between state across so props
can change up the hierarchy you can
change some values of the component
hierarchy like you might have stayed at
your top-level honey it does a state of
play let's continue the kittens like you
advocating to top-level going and that
might pass the kids back down to their
component that doesn't actually care
let's actually change the kittens but it
just wants to read read only from the
kittens coming down those you'd pass
through cross-industry all props this is
kind of like a you would hear the child
components inherit the state
terms I was to get off to Natalie hits
and in fact I'll show exactly how that
happens and building before we act that
does it also makes sense to kind of
think of it like a component can change
its own state but it should never change
its own props that's yeah it's actually
a very safe way to play but it can
change the props of components that did
in turn down at down the chain it
controls or create as positive all right
right this is probably there are yep
that is a great point and for those of
you who are using closure strip that's a
good snake Republic on himself it was
also a mutable mutable Jas and there's a
lot of really cool things you can do
when you introduce the two beautiful
paradigms internet but it's not
requirement he's back in this case we
are you doing very beautiful agencies in
background in just my prior to your lr
return where you are
so you don't have to wrap oh no that's
what you're doing there right house
there's no quotation around the HP
motherboard is occurrence the
preprocessor demands yeah yeah yeah so
this like in a non preprocessor look
like this building up strings but this
is using jss like this is why I have to
run this thing and consult its output so
so we am just going to take your
JavaScript it's going to read it into
some of them just normal job is great
yeah so this is what the output job and
you don't have to use jsx but this is
helpful for designers who are a Chanel
so you can see this is the output
JavaScript it looks just like normal
JavaScript only uses the purpose that
create only cool so running this is
essentially similar to what we did with
the back burning up why are some events
and debris renders as you favorite
things so we're getting closer to what
how back when I was like finally we're
not having anything happen on remove so
this will be do it opportunity to
introduce how the event handlers work in
react and so in our background app for
instance or using jQuery you'd be
familiar with this kind of thing where
you have a dominant attached to an
element and then you have a pullback and
react looks pretty similar but because
we have our virtual Dom inside of our
components it's actually just right
inside of the JFX or react description
so that actually ends up looking more
like this where you have something that
looks more like a templating language on
click pass in the brackets and then
described being call back to the arm
click which is soft remove favorite and
so again this is the equivalent of that
remove function of you it's just going
to do remove the kitten from my
favorites that question reference
through cross
and we're now in a state that looks
exactly like that yes this is
like you inspect them
so that's a good question and not Hydra
sent for the inner workings of how a
business like yes essentially that like
if I run some jQuery so this is like you
can start to see how reactions building
up its own little Dom but against going
back to hold its virtual Dom that react
ash let's dish out puts an actual Dom
and it attaches a bad one so for all
intents purposes quitting on us alive is
the same sort of setup that might have a
picture here background but with reacts
virtual Dom it's really smart about
being able cleanest and we're talking
reminder you da man actually I put that
answer your question yeah so they're
actually facebook is building a set of
front plugin cool to be able to inspect
and debug virtual Dom as simply as you
could real gone but personally having
used react sensibly actually having
my ass feels virtual Dom yeah it's not
so loud I mean is it surprising that I
haven't been frustrated by not having
it's one of the situation is so sure
that well actually the one of the ways I
and all sighing complexes simply design
spaces in states like running name to
anything to a component I actually
structure my projects and ways that this
CSS and react elements and tests are all
in one directory and so it's very clear
to see namespace all the CSS and this
dry period by this name just a small
school
are you doing some sort of variables
javascript in your amazing writer they
have how would you make those dry yeah
so I have an adult when it's wet
facebook also has a project that tries
to solve all your problems five
basically like free processing means
facing your CSS be able to reuse
variables between javascript CSS person
i've gotten by very well with just a
simple main station cotton and just
treating so what's that you have a
global style it's like text typography
silent that would be coupled to your
top-level proponent and your namesake
spreads option so if you have a computer
new high rpm shuffle prince a nap
through include global size sheets ready
at nine and
downstream yeah it's just this is just
like a very and I can show you when I
get into actual so you're using so
you're using look
chuckles yes yeah so yeah it's literally
just like if it's coupled to the
component doesn't actually is really use
outside of it nice taste like component
if its use elsewhere our tree festival I
think you explained this already but
back in the code yeah i just want to
mention it seems really important i want
to make sure i understand a line 86
looks like you mutating props yes what
explain why that's not okay so this is
going back to like an anti-pattern where
it is very simply introducing reacties
as soon as we can to insisting that
gonna in a pure react at or like wrath
way wouldn't want to be mutating
prosecco because it's passing we're kind
of like hunting on so she is passing our
background collection into it as props
then we're meeting with in that back
button collection okay so this is the
case we're actually you are mutating the
props but it's just some kind of this
segment anti-pattern yeah but it's sort
of like how you react presently kind of
but changing the moving like the kit is
actually forcing
lectures that I'm getting past the
cosmic remember yeah exactly this is
basically like the easiest way to swap
of you and a more typical event-driven
architecture with a reactant Carney soon
I'll show you what it's like to do it
around play do the horse update through
render the entire right we have a just
really just the just the component so of
course maybe a call first update up the
tree where this isn't because inhabit
sure yet it with rear end you're all
sometimes it's going to manipulations in
the virtual Dom and it's outputting a
diff kinase minimal changes to be
exercised so this because you have one
at the start and remember be able to
fullest of my cat balls is it going to
remember loosing remember chin who's
going to just rip it up people do
something right so the actual Dom
manipulation is I mean I'm not sure what
the most efficient way topping I rugby
but it will probably just like for
instance if it's just the intern HTML
the single Li it will just change the
end
meri Janelle and basically it's
constantly updating this virtual Dom see
more performant and smart about how he
treats the dip and calculus it's cool so
yeah that's that's implementing
reactionary simple way existing faculty
much and now I think I'll dive into
reacts from the ground up are there any
more questions yep you can do output to
JavaScript Sameer on your magnifying on
that so this this is the first step to
that way build process where it outputs
for just yet and then you run some
passive minifying
this
yes be a great internal question of mine
set ups and SEO concerns so the great
thing about react is with its virtual
Dom it has a method called render to
string that's like this only instead of
specifying a Dom element and adding it
to the actual Dom you do render to
string and outputs in HTML string so
given that you in this case you can't
use back down on the server not be able
to render turn on the server but if
you're using vanilla data or not using a
lot of clients I've only stuff you can
actually use reaction server and render
everything on the server or render
pieces on the server and optimization
page load in SEO and a heart see we
don't explicitly do this with react yet
but we definitely do a lot of this
what's called exome or Vic javascript
share mine
cool so that to answer your question the
implications are if you're willing to
put in the effort that we can optimize
Seok blur and good server-side and
client-side rendering pretty difficult
but if you set up right way it's not too
insane however a lot of people like
argue various ways one more the other
that if you're building something that's
stateful with clients like that be my
magic ation that doesn't need SEO but in
my opinion you can do anything and
definitely like it's not up to you
should with an especially heartsease
case for that symptom okay so building
them the ACT app from the ground up we
just finished introducing react in a
small way through a back when app or in
love with it we want to do it all the
right way so the way we're going
approach this is actually pretty similar
to how we introduce reactions are
backing up we're going to start with
going back to this the very simple
render you always start with what is
just trying to get some HTML output
render a static component or set it free
of compliance so here we go here's step
here we go here's step one of a react
app rewriting our this the same athlete
is heading back down completely react so
we're not going to use background models
of questions at the top similar to talk
a little flexion to the novice have
top-level vanilla data though mine isn't
is pulling out a fixture of data to get
things started this is full list of
kittens which is this whole list here
and again favorites kittens at the
bottom of this tray and we just want to
start rendering something so i'm going
to start rendering some scaffold here so
again we now that i'm like full reactive
and build hierarchy of things and so we
have our list view which is or listening
party in this case which renders the
list and deals with all of the state
involved in this list we have a tray i'm
going there's a list of minute Trey
component that deals with the state of
this UI down here and now we need since
those are just kind of floating around
on their own side by side we now need a
top-level component to finish the trees
so we're going to create an app
component that does not much more but
handle stuff of the two things share and
acid a panic so in our top level
component we're adding the list and this
should look familiar from when we did
our render at the bottom of four
that basically again with j sx to kind
of describe describe your financing an
HTML like syntax and in this case now
build dom hierarchy reminiscing other
components mistake for referencing this
listing on it and it's straight up and
for starters were just going to write a
list so let's pass in our list of
kittens as props from the app down into
the list component and here's where we
actually go through the work to matt our
kittens into a bunch of their lies so
this is the function that returns some
more jsx tom virtual done and iterate
through it it's good set out in two UL
adds a little next page button and for
our tray we're just going to ignore it
for now i'm out of oil container is that
all make sense so far just
yes so right now
list yet is Trey already have access to
we're going to explicitly give it access
so right now because we didn't pass in
this down here we have no props right so
it was just this statelets component has
nothing going also accepted yep
yeah yes it jsx can yeah definitely
knows about local variables and you
still have to do a passing around itself
and why not but essentially you anything
you right inside here has access to the
ship cool so let's take a look at what
that looks like
okay I'll put some get it run my food
processor for Jo sex so here we have a
list of let's see this crap right on
sorry
okay that's so here again we got a whiny
little kitten to our list and Matt
component is rendering that one little
kitten poor guy doesn't even seem to
have a name but you can see that all
it's doing is very through this one LMAO
like spitting out some gum or Trey just
the container at the bottom doesn't even
have
at least we've gotten our you apart one
hierarchies built up and now we can
start to flush out the rest of ya so the
next step will be to write some initial
state our kittens are going to change
over time we're going to favorite some
of them they're going to update our
favorites or favorite sets take our
kittens might go to next page so that's
some state so both of these things are
going to be treated as a form of state
down the line so step two is what's add
some states are less let's focus on the
less will betray later for starters
react at this function get initial state
this is how you declare what the initial
state of your prime is and stay to
supper tunes over time so in this case
our kittens which is this list of
kittens is going to meet over time
because we might hit the next button and
get the next pinky fittings component
did mount this is what's called a light
cycle function in react and that a life
cycle function lets you look into the
bike cycle of rendering react so might
have component did now like I remember
the names Tom ahead but after render
before renderer component did update etc
so you're able to look into sort of
every step of this process and in this
case we want to this is essentially the
initializing back on view in this case
we just want to start by getting the
next page this would be like fetching
the next page of kittens so we call this
next page our render pretty much looks
the same rendering out the if the
kittens but in this case so notice
something different moves hitting that
across because we knew it was going to
change over time we made it into state
and so now we're rendering based off the
kittens state and finally to show how
next page works so in this case we're
actually not passing kittens down into
the hierarchy anymore we're starting
engine on kittens list cares about the
city it means nothing says so the list
is going to get the next page opinions
and update itself
it's the only component to partly
because mountain kittens and so here we
do here you can imagine doing something
like a cat's fall and passing data
ensure compliance so let's create some
picture of kittens here we're going to
create a new array of kittens based off
the current state of pins so we have 30
new tenants and currently we have no
kittens we're going to add those 30
kittens into our current zero emissions
and update the state of our component by
doing this sets fate which is going to
update the kittens to the new cat
kittens and that would cause the
components rerender and this is
basically the general like lifeblood of
writing reads fateful react components
as you use this set state and react is
able to calculate through the various
types of this sub-state what needs to be
updated in a whole tree and just kind of
trickle down all you I can be updated an
efficient way so i'll go ahead and show
what that looks like and then open up
your questions so here you we did our
initial batch of kittens fetch which was
calling next page
running out so that's why you seeing
this first list we haven't added oh ok
one more piece so in our button as if
you remember how event handlers work
we've also wired up the next page to the
button click so when we click this next
button it will run this code of code by
creating a new array of kittens with the
cat kittens and updating our state with
the new expanded array so you'll get an
extra big so does that all make sense so
far so it's kind of like you basically
back hold out for you that can you just
initiate both in the base use regular
phone whereas now you're just
initializing this is the page and then
initialize the window it's all the kids
so you could do something similar in
background the criminal background would
be just adding to the kids collection
which we were doing but I've sent them
everything's fun and likewise you could
do affection paintings and the
initialize function the difference
subtle difference here which makes
bigger differences online is that we're
explicitly calling out what is changing
el de us and we are explicitly updating
kittens like kontakion bringing out new
array updating this internal students
component so this is all kind of
self-contained summarizing background in
architecture decathlete this mock is a
collection it's like this pool is
founder that's which we're going to sell
on the small scope but in a larger scope
if you get really messy if you have a
lot of events going all over the place
whereas reacts build a very clear
direction state change in the flow and
you explicitly call out which parts
would care about which state changes
were at some back more background event
out you'd be like events
yeah yeah I'm doing I would generalize I
browser private party thanks will not
put you in this vanilla script at
excited to a Donnelly style sorry okay
so yep just so you can do you can pass
in multiple things like would you have
to yeah i think so i don't know i don't
know if you can do like that's happening
you know if you have kitchens and food
as your visual so when you stake oh now
you can even have maybe this passing
whatever you want to change so you just
guess in an object that has properties
corresponding to the things you want to
change the lesion of
fields on your state of ya know so you
all the way of you know you shouldn't
i'm going to stay hot Jack Reese
obsessing okay once it is little bit
fields there's no way to communicate the
fact that you want to remove right so
you would bite proximal that fits there
is a really kind of mattress or on the
vine like I kind of adds a bunch of
pitcher you actually want to delete
cookies of our state object
so that I'm single
yes
so we accessed some of the consistent
since plaques classes is called class
name and they have a bulldog from all
the attributes that are there Saul
difference is that when i started which
was to like HTML inside me now no sir
component anak is basically happens only
totally happy once the person i rendered
cultural question what you think this is
the same survey party
if you're not
I do actually so I all don't know where
it's used at artsy but there's
definitely in heavy staple chunks of you
I it becomes a lot more obvious how
updates of happening with react rays
background it's easy to fall into a mess
of events and also if you care about
performance react basically easy to just
rely on ever hold on cool so let's go on
to the next step which is sorry
okay I think we're gonna move on to
showing those frameworks and then
hopefully wrap up our app pretty quick
here so we did a list on the next page
going on we have our state's out there
okay right so now we want to be able to
add to our favorites and we're still
just concerning ourselves with just a
list the list component here and so
right now I'm not thinking outside of
the box I'm good solutions are the list
and add this to the state of the list
and be able to add the functionality
where you know when we put here
nothing's happening so this will be an
example of how we might update for
instance internally inside this
component you want these things to be
favorited so
like we did before we're going to have a
vent handler here on click do on
favorite likewise setstate favorites are
padded burden of the kittens so now
we're just adding to our favorites data
sorry this one I don't think I thought
this one out as much as yo this is it's
going to be a quick demo of taking this
step right there so now we have to pay
the functionality functionality very
similar sort of what we've been doing
before this component has its own state
favorites change the list of things that
are favorited are changing your time so
we're using for adding the state and
adding it an event handler a virtual Dom
that call set state to update that
they're going to jump in this set when
once there's any questions about that so
let's go ahead and flush out the whole
thing sorry this is going to be a big
step we're going to take care but
basically now we want to start having
our tray component and this happens all
the time personally at least when
building out largely occupies is you
have a piece driving account for you
realize that you're actually sharing
some state between them
listview we were sharing them favorites
between these two new eyes so how do we
deal with this we started by adding all
of that state we calculated slowly and
list component how do I get that to be
shared in to trade you coming well in
react it's actually for the most part
you can basically rely on moving that
state height of my chain so as you
remember we have this app component
that's not doing anything yet but
combining these two so what do we do to
be able to share the favorites between
the list and then straight component we
actually move that state up the tree
into the app and now the app is going to
pass that down into my children so here
I've moved the state from of favorites
outside of the list up to the top of the
tree it's an app and now we're passing
those things in as Korea as cross
yeah when I tetanus put to the favorite
state of where we hopefully have you put
the label favourited there and vent and
pray out the selection and avenge
ethically unclick to go in for Zetas yep
so this is a good example of how react
is better than not imperative and jQuery
you might do elements on my class oh man
done remove class in this case we just
described in our jsx if the fit is
favorited Agra class otherwise empty
glass and we check that by being like is
there a kitten in my favorites that
has the same ID as the one that writes
but this this current is all open source
and on github so you need to dive in
some are the details that might
encourage so we moved our state up the
tree and now the list doesn't care about
favorites anymore because two components
depend on it so you move it up and now
we're passing that as props so all the
times in grants fist got state that
favorites inside our list we're now
actually a reference the props this yes
so this one favor that then I soon
writing itself injects right good luck
with that yep as I hope favor that's no
big event right is that is that likes a
tribute vanishes yeah so I'll give this
in a segment visit react without adding
more like flats pictures Facebook's
larger architecture for being able to
move things out of Justin new hire
hierarchy reacts encourages passing call
backs down the down entirety to be able
to do functionality so i'll show you how
that works in the segment so yeah it's a
good segue so now we need to be able to
say once we click on one of these
favorited things it needs to update the
distance a favorited and it needs add it
to the betray and so because the state
has been moved up that means the list is
no longer responsible for favorites
state the app app taco run is now so it
also asks me responsible for what
happens when you favorite things so
we're going to pass down call back we're
passing in our own favorite function
down to the child components here and
what our favorite does is it simply
updates its state to add whatever pain
in favorite stories in it
and likewise when we remove a kitten
from our tray because the state is
managed by the top level component we
have to pass out and fall back to the
tray which is enroute past a call back
to the listening moment look at this
operator is it finding the scope to that
instance because like it looks like it
would be asking down below you know the
references rice so I think react
implicitly minds when you pass it on
function as a property to whatever that
that's so if it's cool by doing this now
instead of having a list a set my own
state what we end up doing is he passes
on favorite callback and instead of
having and before we had a on click
referencing its own call back but did
its own state manipulation now we're
passing in a call back from the top down
into the chalking finance property and
it's basically saying
I'm gonna call my callback here's the
kitten you need buckets at e3 regrets so
at a high level when whenever you need
to move sheriff state between two
components to move it up a tree and it
also means you're probably going to need
something call backs up a tree because
the quantity marijuana managing around
saving affiliation they could just say a
parent you manipulate your safe for me
yes yeah exactly so we're just directly
saying my self crops aren't they great
call back with this kitten and so to
wrap up with the tray running here all
it's really doing now is rendering I
guess I haven't implemented the removing
of the tray but essentially because we
passed down our favorites into the tray
all it needs to do and because it
doesn't manage the state of the
favorites so it's just a static
component right now rendering we top
level favorite state and so there's no
advantage there so just take a look that
looks like
now we got our training and our list and
aha okay right because we passed me on
our Moon favorite as all back against
the parents the one abduction women
homeless right because it actually
maintains the shared bit of state which
is the thing sort of the favorites so
this is the one that stepson say that
tells its children update so all this
was going to do is actually say a parent
here's the kidney and so all in all we
thought would save ourselves like maybe
seven and lots of code from the back
perhaps react out but the wings here are
that as your app grows a lot bigger it's
a lot easier to reason about because you
have a waiter hierarchy and you actually
end up producing a lot of go down line
because you don't have some explicitly
wire up events across a huge system so
that wraps up my demo of wraps back down
and get react from the ground up so
let's see i'll go ahead i'll just
quickly demo how it's used at artsy and
they'll finish up with my lassie sides
oh go ahead and skip tension in my study
but if anyone's interested got me
afterwards so how this is how i use
react in part c currently we have a
product that's cold artsy writer
like wordpress for artsy we have a whole
upcoming super-secret magazine effort
which is a way to premium eyes or
editorial and so we've created where I'm
in the midst of building a rich particle
creator and we're doubling parts writers
so most of this is a noted backbone app
but the this big portion of section 5 is
all react and other portions like even
small bits here where we might be
associating this to partners a lot of
complete widgets these are actually time
will react components but this is the
main like cuckoo know that does a bunch
of reactie so you can see how this is
like a large hierarchy of reacts
components are already two together
beta
so these are all this is all like this
entire list here is like a list
component inside of it it's obsession
container component click into it it's a
text section component we have for
instance in a case like this where
there's various components like little
you I inside of different UI this is
these are little components that are
like text area rich text area components
that are a part of this larger artwork
McConnell it's a part of the larger
section container component that's a
part of a larger section list component
so you can see how react and scale big
really to conceal them make really large
Titans cool so
to finish up here I kind of already went
over this but what were some of the
winds that it's hard to tell smaller
projects like I said earlier it reduces
boilerplate and then keeping bookkeeping
as your UI gets larger than clutch the
one-way data flow is actually often lot
easier to reason about especially in
larger complexification and say finding
like two-way binding you can basically
write their UI as if we were rendering
the entire tree or the entire element
not have to worry about performing super
virtual Dom the components are really
nice for rebuilding composability
testability because they use a virtual
Don you don't actually have to grill the
Firefox browser and one rounds when you
can actually be accessed your components
there's simple to start with like a show
you can start small but they're powerful
even at scale behind having to add one
who ever made to it final it's a nice
things like server-side rendering so
thank you very much
so like putting on JavaScript app inside
like a webview or what I'm definitely
react will help you in terms of a get
off my comments very well and exploit
actually facebook also recently
announced react native rich the cool
thing about the act is you write your
speed you're gonna since effective way
sometimes are such a powerful pattern
you're in your outfit does not please on
actually eat whatever you want declares
state and answered way applications
without but need a huge is also a plate
can this be my project that GL may not
hear the Alpha actual view how could
have react it could be anything yeah
which is the cool potential